[Music]  Haidee TV viewers it is throwback  Thursday and guess what Charlie we're  gonna throw back to you nor O'Donnell  alright it was five years ago that you  joined us at the table where is it time  gone look at that that's our first  picture oh my goodness Wow  we're wearing our colors this week Norah  O'Donnell Wow time to time clock I know  well thank you bravo Bravo Rose I'm so  grateful to get to work with the both of  you every day you make it so worthwhile  and no I'll agree somebody just the  other day that says I love the three of  you I love with the three of you the  interaction between the three of you and  I actually think it's like a  three-legged stool or menage a trois  whichever you'd like I like the ladder  likes to look for you happy thank you  very much